when a black billionaire meets a white
billionaire do you think there's any
racism do you think they care he's a
billionaire I'm a billionaire both are
Yachts are in Monaco he's from Algeria
he stole all the gold I'm a stock market
whatever there's no racism the racism is
for the poor people because if you keep
the poor people divided they can't wake
up long enough to do what I did and read
about how money works because if they do
that we ain't got big trouble right then
the slaves will wake up you don't want
to deprogram the slaves so you have to
convince the slaves that it's not the
monetary system fault that you're broke
it's not the monetary system's fault
that you continue to work for a set
number of dollars and the price of
houses just keep going up and up and up
it's not the Monterey system's fault
it's the white man's fault or the black
man's fault or the Asian people's fault
someone else's fault I think all this
stuff feminism racism all these things I
think they're all control mechanisms
they have to keep the poor people
fighting amongst each other because if
the poor people all unite then it's much
harder to control us